so in the City of Canton in Imperial
China in the early 19th century
vaccination was willingly adopted and a
key reason for this was that it was
promoted by the local Gentry the Gentry
are either State officials or they're
closely linked to the state through
their having been conferred a degree in
the Imperial exam system but they also
have strong ties to society a system of
Confucian norms and the Mandate of
Heaven prompts the local Gentry over
many sanctuaries to be responsible and
accountable for the welfare of people so
they enjoy a long Legacy of trust and
authority and the way that the Gentry
endorses this new generian vaccine was
by embedding it within traditional
established ways of thinking about and
treating smallpox
one of the ways that the Gentry promoted
vaccination was by writing prefaces for
a vaccination manual written by one of
the first vaccinators in southern China
who had learned the technique from the
Surgeon General of the East India
Company Alexander Pearson
chuoshi's manual was technically a
translation of a manual written by
Pearson but the translation did a few
things to creatively link the vaccine to
the principles and practices of Chinese
medicine for one chiroshi got rid of
this whole method of inoculation
discovered in the Kingdom of England so
he changes the title he adopts the
writing style and the illustrations of
traditional Chinese medicine texts a
further sinusization is that he adopts
the same pre and post-operative dietary
and ritual protocols that had
accompanied variation
and finally remember that variation had
happened in Canton through nasal
encephalation you're snorting the scabs
up your nose and now in the vaccine
there is an incision into the arm via
vaccination Lancet that is radically new
Jersey and the Gentry who are endorsing
his manual make this acceptable by
linking it to the familiar needling
technique of acupuncture vaccination
manuals such as this use ornate
illustrations in traditional drawing
styles to show vaccinators how to make
incisions along acupuncture meridians
that corresponded with smallpox
the customary cooling diet was also
maintained and often the generic vaccine
was accompanied by traditional herbal
formulas in contrast the vaccine meets
with a far cooler reception in 19th
century Calcutta it arrives at exactly
the same time in both Canton and
Calcutta it's introduced by the same
agent the East India Company and these
cities are key entrepores in the
European especially the British trading
system in fact trade between Calcutta
and Canton silver tea and eventually
opium is the lifeblood of British
imperialism and you can get a sense of
the importance of the two cities from
this painting of the three money
Brothers all employed by the British
East India company that was commissioned
by their father Mr Money where the
fingers of Robert and James money are
pointing to Canton and Calcutta
respectively so Calcutta shares many
socioeconomic political similarities
with Canton but unlike in Canton the
vaccine in Calcutta is resisted an
important reason is that British
colonial officials do not have the same
degree of trust or legitimacy as the
Gentry further be because the colonies
spread of vaccination was part of a
civilizing mission this led them to
present the vaccine as something totally
new and different from the established
practice of variation especially the
worship of sitala in which varilation
was embedded
so variation which as I mentioned was
very effective and in fact formed the
basis of knowledge on which Jenner built
was now described by the East India
Company in Calcutta as backward and is
dangerous
and yet even though the technology of
the vaccine was very similar to
variulation much more similar than in
Canton because people were accustomed to
having an incision into their skin yet
most residents of Calcutta and the
surrounding areas of Bengal avoided
vaccination and continued to prefer
valuation